okay welcome back so in this segment
what we're going to do is we're going to
use the cayley-hamilton theorem to show
that if and only if a system is
controllable meaning that this matrix
has full rank then any state is
reachable then I can steer X to any
vector in RN with some control input u
okay so here we're going to really show
what it means to be controllable in
terms of the fact that we can reach any
state in RN with some inputs if this
matrix has full rank and we're going to
use cayley-hamilton
so remember cayley-hamilton theorem says
that this matrix a satisfies its own
characteristic equation which means that
I can write this e to the a T as a sum
of a finite series of powers of a up to
a to the N minus 1 with these time
varying coefficients now actually
computing these time varying
coefficients may or may not be very
difficult but the fact that I can
represent this as a finite sum is going
to allow me to mathematically show that
reach ability and controllability are
equivalent and notice this power of a to
the n minus 1 is the same as in our
controllability matrix okay so remember
if we have reach ability so reach
ability so that condition essentially
says that if some vector C in RN is
reachable then what does this mean then
that means then essentially there is
some prescribed trajectory some
prescribed control and put U that will
give me C so C will equal this integral
from 0 to T of e to the a t minus tau
times B times U of tau D tau and this is
for some U of T now I'm not going to
tell you what u of t is but if a
State is reachable then there is some
you so that C will equal this integral
because this is the solution of my
system with zero initial conditions okay
and so what we're going to do here is
we're going to essentially take this
cayley-hamilton expression for e to the
eighty and we're going to pop it into
here and we're going to now expand this
out as a finite matrix product okay so
let's just work this out and let's say
this is going to be a little bit long
but let's say C equals what does it
equal integral 0 to t and we're going to
write this expression out as all of
these terms and remember it's e to the
80 minus tau so every time you see a T
here it's going to be a t minus tau so
what do we have we have V naught t minus
tau times an identity matrix times B
times U of tau so U of tau times
identity be okay and I don't going to
write my detail yet I'm going to keep
all of this under the integral ok the
next term I'm going to have a plus Phi 1
t minus tau u of tau and now instead of
identity B I'm going to have a times B a
B plus dot dot dot plus C n minus 1 t
minus tau U of tau a to the N minus 1 B
all of this integrated with respect to
tau so notice that I've taken this
relatively nasty convolution integral
and because I can plug in this finite
sum of matrices I have a finite set of
terms and these are just scalar
convolutions right the convolution of V
with respect to U or with you and since
I'm integrating with respect to tau and
these matrices are not Towel varying I
can break this up into a bunch of
integrals and pop those matrices
OUTFRONT so this one is going to equal a
b matrix times this integral of towel
which I'm just going to say the integral
0 to t v 0 t minus tau u tau D tau okay
so that's one integral this one plus a B
integral 0 to T now if t 1 t minus tau u
of tau d tau plus dot dot dot okay so
now we're splitting this up into
separate integrals integral 0 to t of
this matrix sorry I need to pop that out
front so I've got a plus dot dot dot
plus a to the N minus 1 B times this
convolution v n minus 1 t minus tau u of
tau D tau okay so this state see if it's
reachable can be written as this sum of
integrals for some U and now the cool
thing is this is just a convolution
integral this is like a number okay or a
set of or a small vector if u is
multiple channel but this is something i
can evaluate in the integral and i can
essentially write this as b a b dot dot
dot a to the N minus 1 b times another
matrix of all of these convolution
integrals integral 0 to t of v naught t
minus tau u of tau D tau integral 0 to t
of v 1 of t minus tau u of tau d tau and
so on and so forth all the way down to C
integral 0 to t fe n minus 1 t minus tau
u of tau D tau ok so this is super
interesting right this C can be written
as this product of the controllability
matrix has all these cons
oceans of these these time varying
coefficients with my control input you
and so what this tells us is that if
this controllability matrix has full
rank has hasn't sorry not full rank if
it has rank n if it spans all of our n
then essentially I can choose there
exists some coefficients in this sector
where if I take that linear combination
I'll get any key in RN so what that says
is essentially if this matrix is rank n
if the spans all of my state space then
I can essentially cook up some you some
linear combination of these that will
get me to any state in my state space
which is really remarkable so this you
use cayley-hamilton to show that our
controllability is equivalent to reach
ability because if this is full rank
that's the only way that my states are
reachable and in fact the converse is
even easier to see if this does not span
certain directions in RN there is no way
I can cook up some linear combination to
get those directions because it's just
not in this column space okay so it's a
really useful idea and I like to ask ask
my students a simple question is there a
unique U of T that gives me this C can I
cook up a unique u that will give me
this see if my systems controllable so
let you think about that for a minute
well I draw a little picture okay let's
say this is my state space RN and let's
say that this is my desired C so I would
say there is not a unique you there are
infinitely many use that could give me
this state if my system is controllable
and so the idea here is I could develop
a you that would get me to this point by
some roundabout path so there's some use
it will take me to the state taking this
path and there's a totally different you
that will take me to this state in the
straight line path okay and any other
path so there are in fact into
many use they will reach this state if
the system is controllable and the way I
like to think about it is the following
there are essentially n coefficients or
maybe n times the number of control
inputs so if u is in our queue if
there's Q control knobs then there are n
times Q unique numbers I need to specify
to get this C okay and in fact if Q is
not equal to 1 there are multiple of
these column vectors that will get me to
the same C so there are multiple ways of
using those control knobs to get sixy
but because the function U is this
continuously varying function it's
infinite dimensional it has many many
more degrees of freedom than just n
times Q and so it has the freedom to get
to C in any number any infinite number
of paths okay but I just want to show
you that first of all cayley-hamilton is
extremely useful it gives us a
representation that allows us to write
this convolution integral in terms of
our controllability matrix okay and then
you can show that if the system is
controllable that it's reachable and
vice versa okay so next we're going to
solve this on some actual examples we're
going to like really look at if a system
is controllable and then we're going to
develop controllers